[Música]
te presento a la tribu más violenta del
mundo conocidos como los sentineleses
el año pasado en 2018 mataron a un
misionero que quería evangelizar les y
la policía de la india todavía no se ha
atrevido a recoger el cuerpo
nadie que haya contactado con ellos ha
regresado por eso los sentineleses han
permanecido aislados del mundo durante
siglos en esta isla remota situada en el
océano índico y nadie se atreve a
visitar a los sentineleses
a estas alturas te preguntarás por qué
te estamos hablando de esta tribu tan
violenta pues muy sencillo estas islas
pertenecen al archipiélago de andamán y
nicobar y en contra de lo que puede
parecer esta ristra de islas es
fundamental para el comercio
internacional básicamente todos los
petroleros que llegan a china pasan por
aquí eso significa que en cualquier
momento la india podría bloquear el
tráfico y colapsar toda la economía
china en cuestión de meses
[Música]
y creedme podría ocurrir la india no es
precisamente un buen amigo de china y
que está naciendo en beijing para evitar
todo esto estamos hablando de el inicio
de una guerra bueno esperemos que no
la respuesta es mucho más complicada que
todo esto los que seguís visual polític
desde hace tiempo ya os estaréis
imaginando de por dónde voy exacto el
collar de perlas en este vídeo os
contaremos cómo china y la india se
están amenazando mutuamente vamos a
verlo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en anteriores episodios de visual
política os contamos como china
amenazaba al imperio americano esto es a
los eeuu
la iniciación apple tan road y sobre
todo su versión marítima a la que
llamamos el collar de perlas son la
estrategia china para neutralizar la
influencia estadounidense en el océano
índico
[Música]
si recordáis lo llamamos collar de
perlas porque cada perla representa un
puerto chino que podría convertirse en
una base militar pero eeuu no son los
únicos que están preocupados por esta
posible expansión militar ahora vamos a
ver cómo la india también tiene razones
para tener miedo pero antes os estaréis
preguntando dónde están estas perlas que
quiere colocar china pues estas perlas
están en algunas zonas como bangladesh y
blanca o pakistán
[Música]
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
en principio ninguno de estos proyectos
son militares
en todos los casos hablamos de puertos
comerciales aeropuertos autopistas así
que dónde está el problema las
autopistas son buenas para la economía
no o para ya de repente está mal que los
chinos quieren hacer dinero por supuesto
que no pero la pregunta es de verdad
quieren hacer dinero o en realidad están
movidos por otro tipo de intereses vamos
a poner un ejemplo el puerto de hanban
tota en sí la ncaa
este blanca es un país que tuvo una
guerra civil hace unos años y que está
hecho unos zorros y el puerto de hanban
tota está por ahí muerto de risa para
que os hagáis una idea en el año 2017
sólo 183 barcos pasaron por ahí
[Música]
pues bien china ha invertido la friolera
de 1000 millones de dólares en este
puerto por si fuera poco han construido
toda una ciudad a su alrededor desde
cero tiene sentido económico pues más
bien no ahora bien si lo miramos desde
un punto de vista militar tener un
puerto al ladito de la india le viene de
perlas a china y aquí es donde vienen
los miedos y si lo que china está
intentando realmente es expandirse
militarmente
ha pensado bien por extraño que parezca
china está en una posición
extremadamente débil muchos países
pueden bloquear sus rutas comerciales en
cualquier momento y creerme tanto la
india como japón estarían encantados de
hacerlo es más no lo hacen ahora en
parte porque américa no quiere pero
claro visto el cariño que tiene donald
trump a los chinos no sería raro que un
día cambiarán las cosas en otras
palabras que china tiene lo que llamamos
un riesgo existencial y para eso
necesitan tener bases militares fuera
del país y aquí es donde vienen los
problemas
[Música]
un país va a dejar que china construya
sus bases militares en su territorio
nacional y lo que es más importante
bastaría con unas bases militares para
que china estuviera segura por ejemplo
porque tener un puerto en sir lanka es
tan importante para china hoy vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
la diplomacia del sugar daddy in para
los que no lo conozcáis y de la ncaa es
esa isleta que está al sur de la india
tienen alrededor de 21 millones de
habitantes y si nunca habéis oído hablar
de ellos no os preocupéis hasta ahora su
importancia política era más o menos
cero así que os voy a hacer un resumen
de lo que pasa por aquí
[Música]
durante 26 años sin blanca sufrió una
guerra civil con un grupo terrorista
los tigres libertadores del tamil eelam
hablamos de un conflicto donde más de
60.000 personas perdieron la vida
algunas estimaciones hablan de hasta
100.000 personas como os podéis imaginar
las violaciones de derechos humanos se
dieron en ambos lados y durante décadas
el gobierno decide blanca estuvo aislado
de la comunidad internacional
esto significa que el gobierno lo tenía
muy complicado para conseguir armas con
las que poder luchar contra los tigres
del tamil eelam y en ese momento cuando
todo el mundo le daba la espalda si
granca sólo había un país listo para ser
su amigo o más bien su hogar davis si
amigos de visual política hablamos de
[Música]
del desfile de la victoria de stri
blanca se reveló la ayuda proporcionada
por china estas noticias son del año
2009 año en el que si blanca derrota a
los tigres la guerra había terminado y
en ese momento el flamante presidente
del país era este señor que veis en la
pantalla que se llama mahindra rajapaksa
[Música]
el clásico líder autoritario corrupto y
hambriento de poder llegó al gobierno en
el año 2005 y desde el primer momento
china le ofreció todo ese armamento que
necesitaba para derrotar a los tigres
del tamil eelam de esta forma rajapaksa
podría ganar un montón de credibilidad
como el hombre que terminó con la guerra
civil en sí lanka pero la historia no
también aquí veréis en este mundo no hay
nada más fácil que jugar con el ego de
un señor con ganas de poder y así es
como china se convirtió en el sugar
daddy de rajapaksa
[Música]
por si no lo sabéis un sugar daddy es un
señor muy rico que se dedica a pagarle
un montón de lujos a una chica para que
sea algo así como su novia pues esto es
lo que pasó con sí blanca a ver
rajapaksa que dices que quieres
construir la torre más alta de todo el
sur de asia para que todo el mundo vea
pues claro que sí guapetón aquí está
china con la tarjeta de crédito que
dices ahora rajapaksa que quieres montar
un teatro con un letrero hay gigantesco
con tu nombre para que todo el mundo te
recuerde por los siglos de los siglos
pues claro que es y guapetón aquí está
china con la tarjeta de crédito y ahora
que quiere rajapaksa te apetece
construir un puerto de aguas profundas
en hanban tota para construir si blanca
en la nueva singapur
pues claro que sí y guapetón aquí está
llena con la tarjeta de crédito en otras
palabras sin blanca tiene tantísimos
proyectos de lujo ahora mismo que si
sueltan a tener por ahí se quedaría a
vivir para el resto de sus días y diréis
pero cuánto ha costado semejante lujo
asiático pues no lo saben ni ellos
[Música]
la crisis de la deuda en sir lanka es
tan grave que ni siquiera el gobierno
sabe cuánto dinero debe para que lo
entendáis mejor el año pasado el
gobierno de sir lanka recaudó 14 mil 800
millones de dólares en impuestos pues
bien de todo ese dinero 12 mil 300
millones de dólares se van para pagar
las deudas que tienen principalmente con
china y aún así siguen debiendo dinero y
qué pasa cuando debes dinero a china y
no puedes pagar aquí es cuando viene el
problema de tener un sugar navi al
principio todo es fantástico te pagan
los zapatos de tacón el caviar la
joyería pero luego tienes que dar algo a
cambio y qué es lo que les gusta a los
chinos
[Música]
sin blanca ofrece formalmente el puerto
de hanban tota a las empresas chinas en
un acuerdo de 99 años por supuesto en
este contrato de 99 años está bien
clarito que no pueden usar el puerto
para cosas militares pero a ver quién le
dice a china lo que puede o no puede
hacer con su propiedad con tantísimas
deudas por pagar
rajapaksa no puede decirle que no a su
sugar daddy y ahora os preguntaréis qué
pasará cuando rajapaksa abandone el
poder pues ya tenemos una respuesta
porque lo cierto es que pese a sus
esfuerzos de propaganda y culto a la
personalidad
rajapaksa perdió las elecciones en 2015
sin embargo el dinero no entiende de
propaganda así que la ideología del
nuevo gobierno importa más bien poco si
la banca está entrampada con su deuda
china pero que yo que ya sé lo que
estáis pensando esto es lo que pasa
consideran acá que es un país pequeño
qué pasa con los países más grandes pues
vamos a dar un paseo por pakistán
[Música]
en el puerto de gwadar en pakistán es
otro ejemplo de esto que llamamos la
diplomacia del sugar daddy por cierto
porque no habrá ninguna palabra en
español para describir lo que es un
lugar dado en fin habéis oído hablar
alguna vez de gwadar en pakistán
sí hombre guardar famoso en el mundo
entero por vale yo tampoco había oído
hablar de gwadar en la vida sin embargo
de la noche a la mañana este sitio se ha
convertido en un punto importantísimo
para el corredor china pakistán una ruta
comercial donde china se está gastando
62 mil millones de dólares sólo la
primera fase de la construcción de este
puerto ya ha costado la friolera de 200
millones de dólares el corredor
económico de china pakistán es un
eslabón muy importante en la cadena de
la iniciativa beltrán road y permitirá
la posibilidad de una ruta de la seda
marítima para el siglo 21
en presidente de la comisión de
desarrollo nacional chino pero no solo
hablamos de un puerto china se está
gastando otros dos mil millones de
dólares
en montar una refinería de petróleo por
la zona tiene sentido económico pues lo
cierto es que si un puerto y un
gasoducto por ahí vendría muy pero que
muy bien para conectar asia con oriente
medio de hecho a dar puede convertirse
fácilmente en un centro logístico y
comercial de primera así que si tiene
sentido que china quiera hacer negocios
por ahí pero claro 2000 millones de
dólares también sirven para hacer que el
gobierno de pakistán esté muy pero que
muy contento y dependa muy pero que muy
mucho de ti si quieren mantener todas
las infraestructuras de lujo más le vale
tener contentos a su lugar nadie y por
si no os habíais dado cuenta ya no se
trata de un país pequeño pakistán tiene
200 millones de personas y sorpresa
resulta que son el mayor enemigo de la
india
[Música]
pero ya puestos a hablar de países
vecinos vamos con otro bangladesh
manuales tiene 164 millones de
habitantes de hecho es el país más
densamente poblado del mundo y adivina
quién les vende todo el arsenal militar
que utilizan exacto china y por supuesto
no sólo hablamos de armas china también
está construyendo un puerto de uso no
militar
en total bangladesh le debe 8 mil
millones de dólares a china en otras
palabras que a bangladesh tampoco está
en condiciones de decirle que no a su
lugar dan pero ahora ha esperado un
momento fijaos en este mapa que tienen
en común bangladesh sin blanca y
pakistán
mirando bien dejad lo que estáis
haciendo y mirar la pantalla por un
momento lo veis
[Música]
todos estos países rodean a la india y
porque estos son malas noticias para la
india pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
enemigo a las puertas ya lo veis india
está rodeada de puertos chinos por
supuesto por el momento todos estos
puertos no tienen uso militar pero
podrían tenerlo por ejemplo en el año
2017 un submarino chino quería atracar
en el puerto de sir lanka el gobierno
que ya no era el de rajapaksa denegó el
permiso y pudo hacerlo porque en
principio el contrato que tienen dice
que el puerto de harman total no es para
uso militar pero todo esto puede cambiar
basta que vayan a renegociar su deuda un
día para que china saque el tema militar
y blanca no puede decir que no a su
sugar daddy 1 pero qué significa todo
esto para la india pues volvamos a
nuestras islas favoritas las islas de
andamán y nicobar donde viven los
salvajes sentineleses
como decíamos por aquí la india podría
bloquear rutas comerciales y tal y como
está la cosa hoy en día china no podría
hacer nada en respuesta pero ahora
imaginar lo que pasaría si china tuviera
bases militares rodeando a la india
derrepente china podría enviar tropas a
la india por todos los lados todo eso
explica por qué el primer ministro indio
narendra modi está tan asustado y que
creéis que está haciendo pues una
estrategia que va por dos lados por uno
la vía diplomática
el primer ministro indio narendra modi
visitará china para tener un encuentro
personal con xi jinping pero también hay
otra vía la que podríamos llamar la vía
del círculo veo culo quiero básicamente
si china está construyendo su collar de
perlas india está haciendo lo mismo
[Música]
pero ya sé lo que me vais a decir si no
tienes suficiente dinero como para ir
por ahí por la vida como un azúcar daddy
pero la india vale que van creciendo
muchos años pero no tienen ni punto de
comparación con china entonces si no
tienen dinero que pueden hacer puertas
palabras dar miedo
pensando bien hay un montón de países
preocupados por una posible expansión
militar china y ahí es cuando llega la
india dice pero has visto a la que está
enviando los chinos por ahí mira alguien
tiene que parar los pies a estos tíos
porque es que si no se variara aquí el
despiporre esto va a ser la de dios es
cristo uno de estos países es francia
los franceses están muy preocupados
porque cada día pierden toda esa
influencia que tenían en áfrica y contra
quien la están perdiendo exacto contra
los chinos así que en 2018 el gobierno
de nueva delhi firmó un pacto
estratégico con francia para abrir bases
navales en el océano índico
eso significa que ahora la india tiene
acceso a los puertos de francia en
yibutí pero aquí no termina la cosa
[Música]
un día está luchando para asegurar
alianzas mientras china expande su
dominio naval en lo que era la área de
influencia tradicional de la india todo
esto explica que la india ya esté
construyendo una base naval en las
seycheles y esté negociando con omán
para tener acceso a sus puertos y qué
consecuencias tiene todo esto es que la
india ya tiene su propio collar de
perlas un collar de perlas que va por
madagascar yibutí omán las seychelles
todo el caminito hasta singapur pero
esperad un momento porque la india no es
el único país que quiere pararle los
pies a china el verano pasado la
presidenta de taiwán tsai ming wen dijo
que china es una amenaza para la
democracia global y lo mismo pasa con
tailandia que ya se está asociando con
europa japón y eeuu para hacer frente a
beijing pero no sólo eso si la india
quiere competir con china necesito un
aliado más poderoso y ese no es otro que
japonés
segunda reunión del foro indio japonés
veis lo que estamos viendo
china está intentando rodear a la india
pero la india está intentando rodear a
china en ciencia política a esta
situación se le conoce como duelo
mexicano
un duelo mexicano es una posición donde
dos países controlan una región y
esperan que el otro haga un movimiento
en falso así que que podría pasar por
aquí una escalada militar pues
básicamente a no ser que llegan a un
acuerdo parece que ambos van a seguir
gastando más y más y más dinero en
defensa para evitar un posible ataque
veis como la política es divertida si es
que os tendréis que suscribir todos a
visual político todo el mundo tendría
que suscribirse a visual político porque
ahora muchos me vais a decir y qué está
pasando con eeuu y con europa porque
todo el vídeo casi no hemos hablado ni
de estados unidos ni de europa pues
atentos porque pronto sacaremos otro
vídeo de esta serie sobre el collar de
perlas en el que vamos a hablar de
tecnología pero claro si no os lo
queréis perder pues tendréis que
suscribiros a este canal y darle a la
campanita para que os lleguen todas las
notificaciones al teléfono móvil
mientras tanto la pregunta es para
vosotros veremos como la india y china-
permanecen en un duelo mexicano
permanente cuánto puede durar esta
situación
podéis dejarme vuestra
en los comentarios y si os ha gustado
este vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en
el próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]